[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zur Sallys Welt!
Ich war neulich mit meiner Sarah in Hamburg.
Und da haben wir
Schmalzkuchen gegessen.
Ich habe kurz überlegen müssen, wie es heißt.
Schmalzkuchen.
Und ich weiß noch, ich habe mit dem Kai
Pflaume drüber gesprochen und habe gesagt:
"Was muss ich denn hier in Hamburg probieren?"
Dann hat er gesagt: "Probiert doch mal Schmalzkuchen."
Da haben wir das gegessen.
Und im Prinzip ist Schmalzkuchen einfach
frittierter Hefeteig mit viel, viel Puderzucker.
Und ich habe jetzt kurzerhand beschlossen,
weil viele von euch wirklich nach dem Rezept gefragt haben,
dass ich meine Videoplanung umschmeiße,
ein anderes Rezept rausschmeiße, ins neue Jahr schiebe
und jetzt noch Schmalzkuchen mache.
Also mache ich jetzt hier erst einmal einen Hefeteig.
Das ist ja im Prinzip so, ja, ein Grundrezept.
Ich werde es dann noch verfeinern
mit Vanilleextrakt und Zitronenabrieb
und später, wie gesagt, ausbacken.
Ich verwende jetzt dafür
einen halben Würfel Hefe,
– das ist ein Päckchen Trockenhefe –
100 Gramm Zucker,
50 Gramm Wasser,
500 Gramm Mehl, Dinkel oder Weizen,
zwei Eier,
150 Gramm Milch,
100 Gramm weiche Butter.
Hier habe ich noch einen halben Teelöffel Salz,
eine Prise Zitronenabrieb
und Vanilleextrakt.
Dann kann ich jetzt erst einmal den Zucker
mit der Hefe und dem Wasser verrühren.
Hefe könnt ihr übrigens immer wunderbar einfrieren.
Dann habt ihr auch frische Hefe auf Vorrat.
Denn ich sage zwar oft dazu,
wie viel Trockenhefe ihr nehmen könnt,
aber ich persönlich muss sagen,
ich arbeite lieber mit frischer Hefe.
Und im Vorrat habe ich sie eben
dann einfach im Gefrierschrank.
[Musik]
Und dann knetet ihr den Teig jetzt einfach mit den Händen
oder mit der Küchenmaschine.
Ich gebe jetzt auch hier direkt das Mehl dazu.
Nicht ganz alles.
Dann die Eier.
Milch.
Jetzt erst mal kurz rühren.
Und dann kann ich nämlich zum Schluss noch
das restliche Mehl und die Butter dazu geben.
Das Salz auch immer recht zum Schluss,
weil Salz sich mit der Hefe auch nicht so gut verträgt.
Und die Butter, die soll einfach weich sein.
Also die muss jetzt nicht geschmolzen werden.
[Musik]
Und beim Zitronenabrieb mache ich es auch so:
Ich kaufe ja immer Bio-Zitronen, ungespritzt,
sodass man die Schale mitverzehren kann.
Und wenn ich aber mal keine Zitronenschale brauche,
dann reibe ich sie trotzdem ab und friere sie ein.
Dann habe ich auch immer Zitronenschale auf Vorrat.
Und die Zitrone lohnt sich dann preislich.
Dann kann ich den Saft benutzen
und die ausgedrückte Zitrone dann noch
in den Geschirrspüler mit reinpacken.
Dann ist sie wirklich auch gar nicht mehr so teuer.
So. Vanille rein
und das restliche Mehl.
Es kann natürlich je nach Mehlsorte sein,
dass man bis zu 50 Gramm mehr oder weniger braucht,
je nachdem, was für ein Mehl ihr habt.
Der Teig sollte einfach nur schön weich,
aber nicht mehr klebrig sein.
Und dann knete ihr ihn jetzt einfach
für sieben bis zehn Minuten.
[Musik]
Es ist ein recht weicher Teig.
Also ich habe auch noch mal ein bisschen Mehl dazu gegeben.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier auch
zum Kneten Mehl und kein Fett.
Da fragen nämlich immer ganz viele,
wann ich Mehl benutze zum Kugelformen
und wann ich Backtrennspray nehme.
Also, wenn ich sehe, dass der Teig eben schon
eine perfekte Konsistenz hat,
dann nehme ich einfach Backtrennspray
oder ein bisschen Öl oder Butter.
Und wenn ich sehe, der Teig verträgt noch ein bisschen Mehl,
dann mache ich das hier mit Mehl.
Aber der darf ruhig etwas weicher sein als herkömmlich.
Denn der wird ja nicht geformt, sondern nur geschnitten.
So. Jetzt einfach eine Kugel gleich formen.
Da brauche ich noch ein klein wenig.
Und dann gebe ich ihn wieder zurück in die Schüssel,
kann ihn abdecken
und dann bei Raumtemperatur eine Stunde aufgehen lassen
oder im Backofen bei Gärstufe eine halbe Stunde,
sodass er sich einfach schön verdoppelt.
[Musik]
So. Der Teig ist jetzt wunderbar aufgegangen.
Und ich rolle den jetzt hier kurz aus.
Also ich dachte am Anfang,
dass Schmalzkuchen Schmalzkuchen heißt,
weil er in Schmalz ausgebacken wird, also in Butterschmalz.
Dann schrieb mir jemand:
"Nee, die haben da doch immer Schweineschmalz."
Und ich dachte so: "Ih!"
Aber dann hab ich gelesen,
dass man früher wohl Schweineschmalz benutzt hat
und mittlerweile eben nicht mehr.
Und die meisten benutzen wirklich einfach Butterschmalz.
Ich backe es jetzt nicht in Butterschmalz aus,
weil ich zum einen nicht so viel Butterschmalz dahabe
und zum anderen ist Butterschmalz schon ein wenig teuer,
muss man auch sagen.
Also da muss man ein bisschen...
>> ELA: Was machst du da?
>> SALLY: Und deswegen nehme ich
einfach Sonnenblumenöl,
>> ELA: Achtung, Mama.
>> SALLY: Frittieröl.
Und das kann ich ja dann auch
– wenn ihr Frittieröl habt,
könnt ihr das ja schon ein paarmal benutzen zum Frittieren.
Hey Ela, hilfst du mir mit, Mäuschen?
Und jetzt rolle ich das hier
auf 8 mm Stärke aus.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Ja?
Guck mal. Geh nur von dem Topf weg, okay?
Weil der Topf, da ist heißes Frittierfett drin.
Da muss man immer wegbleiben.
Genau, du darfst das jetzt...
Ah!
Du darfst jetzt hier mal ausrollen.
Und ich hab jetzt das Fett auf 170°C erhitzt.
Also heißer solltet ihr es nicht machen.
160, 170°C passt perfekt.
Ich gehe noch einmal so rum,
damit alle gleich dick werden.
Und ich glaube sogar, wir können sie
auf 5 mm Stärke machen.
Denn die werden ja noch
dick beim Aufgehen im Fett, gell?
Warte kurz. Ich hole kurz die Ringe.
>> ELA: Der ist 8 mm lang.
>> SALLY: 8 mm, stimmt.
Da steht eine 8.
Und ich hole jetzt welche mit 5.
Vielleicht kannst du mir gleich sagen,
auf welchen steht 5, okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: So. Komm mal her.
Auf welchen steht 5?
Ah, super!
Was steht hier?
>> ELA: 3.
>> SALLY: Ja, okay.
Und hier?
>> ELA: Da steht 10.
>> SALLY: Ach, zum Glück habe ich dich.
Ein Glück!
Die Samira hat uns schon verlassen
und steht hinter der Kamera
und wir zwei hier vor der Kamera, gell?
>> ELA: Hm.
Also sie hat schon eine Kamera
und sie hat ein Video gefilmt damit.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> ELA: Samira, wie viele Abonnenten hat das Video?
>> SAMIRA: Das habe ich doch nicht hochgeladen!
>> SALLY: Ja, sie darf ja ihre Videos nicht hochladen.
Die macht die zwar, aber hochladen geht nicht, gell?
>> ELA: Gib die doch selber abholend.
>> SALLY: Ach, Ela.
>> ELA: Ein Video wird das.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hole ich kurz ein
– warte! Lang nicht mehr drauf!
Ich habe es gerade so gleichmäßig gemacht.
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
So. Jetzt müssen wir die mal zuschneiden,
damit die genau so werden,
wie Sarah und ich sie gegessen hatten.
>> ELA: Was?
>> SALLY: Und ich glaube, es waren ja kleine,
so kleine Stücke einfach.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> ELA: Waren das Käsesticks?
>> SALLY: No.
>> ELA: Brotsticks?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> ELA: Was?
>> SALLY: Es waren
– wie heißen sie?
Butterschmalz
– Schmalzkuchen.
So. Du kannst hier den Teig haben.
So. Hier.
Also die sollten jetzt echt nicht zu groß sein.
>> ELA: Ich brauche die größere.
>> SALLY: Ja, dieses Jahr, Mädels,
dieses Jahr gibt es ja keine Weihnachtsmärkte.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, finde ich voll schade.
>> SALLY: Gell? Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Gar kein Schlittschuhfahren.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Mama, gib mir mal kurz das Messer. Ich brauche das.
>> SALLY: Mh. Ich brauche es aber auch.
Was machen wir jetzt?
>> ELA: Warte.
>> SALLY: Dann fragen wir. Wie fragen wir dann?
>> ELA: Mama, kann ich das bitte kurz haben?
>> SALLY: Na klar.
>> SAMIRA: Wenn du doch so lieb fragst.
>> SALLY: Und ich fange einfach schon mal an,
die Schmalzkuchen auszubacken.
Und zwar mache es jetzt so:
Ich lege sie jetzt hier in die Schöpfkelle rein,
lege sie dann ins heiße Fett,
backe sie aus
und danach werden sie zum Servieren
mit Puderzucker bestreut.
Oh, ein Donut!
Den backen wir auch aus.
>> SAMIRA: Ich mache noch einen.
>> ELA: Ich mache richtige Donuts.
>> SALLY: Und dann hole ich Sarah zum Probieren.
Denn mit ihr habe ich sie ja auch das erste Mal gegessen.
>> ELA: Ihr macht keine Donuts. Ihr macht...
>> SALLY: Und da sollt ihr jetzt nur darauf achten,
dass nicht zu viele auf einmal ins Frittierfett kommen,
damit das Frittierfett nicht sofort herunterkühlt.
Da kann es nämlich passieren, dass es dann schäumt.
Also wirklich immer nur wenige ausbacken
und dann die nächsten.
Und man sieht jetzt auch schön,
wie sie sich aufplustern.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich gerade sturmfrei, Ela und Samira sind weg.
Okay, sie ist wieder da.
Ich würde sagen,
ich bereite das jetzt hier mal vor, mache es fertig.
Was machst du?
Klaust du mir gerade Puderzucker?
Ela, ich habe gesagt, keine Glasur.
>> ELA: Bitte. Ich brauche...
>> SALLY: Du hörst so gut wie dein Papa.
Und zwar hatten wir das dort auch
aus so einer Tüte raus.
Und es war einfach
immer wieder zwischendrin Puderzucker.
Ich würde sagen, Sarah, wir zwei probieren, oder?
>> SARAH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Aber du musst sie erst bei mir bestellen.
>> SARAH: Okay.
Aber, damit das Feeling da ist,
ziehe ich meine Winterjacke an.
>> SALLY: Ja.
So. Hallo!
>> SARAH: Hallo!
Ich hätte gerne eine Portion Schmalzkuchen.
>> SALLY: Kleine Tüte, mittlere oder große?
>> SARAH: Groß.
>> SALLY: Alles klar.
Dann gibt es die große.
Hier, bitte.
>> SARAH: Schon fertig?
>> SALLY: Ja, schon vorbereitet.
>> SARAH: Sie sind aber schnell.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Frisch gebacken.
>> SARAH: Danke schön!
Kriege ich auch noch einen Spießer?
>> SARAH: Hast du jetzt gerade...
>> SALLY: Das kommt davon,
wenn man den Deckel nicht drauf macht.
Ich mache mal den Deckel drauf.
Nein!
>> ELA: Yeah!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Yeah!
>> SALLY: Magst du zu mir rum
und einfach einen Spießer mitbringen?
>> ELA: Juppie, Schnee!
>> SARAH: Ja, Josh, komm.
>> SALLY: Ja, Josh.
>> ELA: Mama?
Warum ist Schnee auf deiner Schürze?
>> SARAH: Du hast schon mal den Schnee vorbereitet
>> SALLY: Ich habe den Schnee vorbereitet.
>> SARAH: für unseren Weihnachtsmarkt.
>> SALLY: Für das Feeling gehen wir jetzt raus, okay?
>> SARAH: Ja, ich habe dir deine Jacke.
>> SALLY: Die brauchen hier noch zwei, drei Minuten.
>> SARAH: Ah, ich habe keinen Spießer.
>> SALLY: Ich lasse nur die Ela nicht alleine hier.
Ich nehme sie mit.
>> SARAH: Das ist vielleicht eine ganz gute
>> SALLY: Entscheidung. >> SARAH: Idee.
>> ELA: Angelegenheit.
>> SARAH: Was hat sie gesagt?
>> SALLY: Idee.
>> SARAH: Hat sie Idee gesagt?
>> ELA: Angelegenheit.
>> SALLY: Eine Angelegenheit? Ach so.
>> SARAH: Eine gute Angelegenheit.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja, wir gehen raus zum Probieren.
Weil das Feeling in Hamburg,
das muss schon das gleiche sein.
>> SARAH: Hey, nehmen wir einen Grillspieß?
>> SALLY: Aber es braucht noch jemanden mit so einem
– mit der Ziehharmonika.
Ja, wir nehmen Grillspieße.
>> SARAH: Willst du einen Diamanten oder eine Krone?
>> SALLY: Ich will eine Krone.
>> SARAH: Okay, ich bringe ihn dir mit.
>> SALLY: Heißt dieses Spielinstrument so, was...
>> SARAH: Ziehharmonika.
>> SALLY: Ziehharmonika, nicht?
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Musikinstrument.
>> SARAH: Wie? Mach es noch mal vor.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama, eine Krone ist doch...
>> SARAH: Das sieht aus wie bei einem Heckenfest,
so rum-ba-rum.
>> SALLY: So.
Ela, ich nehme die hier kurz raus
und wir nehmen dich kurz mit.
Denn wir lassen dich nicht allein.
Oh, jetzt sind sie noch so richtig heiß
und dann ist an manchen Stellen viel Puderzucker,
an manche weniger.
>> SARAH: Josh, kannst du Ziehharmonika spielen?
Kann man so eine Musik
einfügen?
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und
>> SALLY: ich finde die sogar besser.
Weißt du warum?
Bei denen war nämlich das Problem,
die hatten kein Salz im Teig
und dann schmeckte das so richtig geschmacklos,
obwohl es süß genug war.
Aber das Salz hat gefehlt.
>> SARAH: Stimmt, das hast du sogar
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SARAH: gesagt gehabt in Hamburg.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte es denen nur am Stand nicht sagen,
weil ich gedacht habe,
nee, will ich nicht.
Mmh!
Wie schön der da vorne Ziehharmonika spielt.
>> SARAH: Hm. Wow!
>> SALLY: Du hast das überall jetzt!
>> SARAH: Komm, wir geben ihm Geld.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Also, wenn ihr auch ein bisschen Weihnachtsmarktfeeling
zu Hause haben wollt,
dann probiert den Schmalzkuchen doch gerne mal aus.
>> SARAH: Oh, mega!
>> SALLY: Wenn wir jetzt noch eine Stunde gewartet hätten,
>> SARAH: Dann wäre es...
>> SALLY: wäre es auch dunkel
und dann wäre es wirklich wie in Hamburg.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann wären hier so die Lichter
im Hof angegangen.
>> SARAH: Ja, stimmt.
Machen wir in einer Stunde...
>> SALLY: O mein Gott, Sarah!
>> SARAH: Wenn du so viel Puderzucker da drauf haust!
>> SALLY: Ojemine!
>> SARAH: Warten wir noch mal.
Hier draußen in einer Stunde.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
Also für euer Weihnachtsmarktfeeling zu Hause
könnt ihr den Schmalzkuchen gerne ausprobieren.
Ist supereinfach, mit wenigen Zutaten,
die ihr wahrscheinlich schon zu Hause habt.
Probiert das Rezept gerne aus.
Das Rezept findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de oder in
>> SARAH: der App.
>> SALLY: Ja. Viel Spaß dabei!
Tschüss!
Und zählt nicht die Kalorien!
>> SARAH: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Machen wir auch nicht.
>> SARAH: Haben wir schon...
>> SALLY: Dort waren sie aber richtig heiß, gell?
Jetzt haben wir ein bisschen zu lang gewartet.
Eigentlich frittieren und sofort raus.
>> SARAH: Aber dort war es auch ein bisschen kälter.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Also geht es,
>> SARAH: gleicht sich wieder aus.
>> SALLY: Oh, lecker!
>> SARAH: Hat man verstanden, was ich sagen will?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Gell?
Du hast es verstanden, Josh nicht.
>> SALLY: Josh, kommst du mit auf den Weihnachtsmarkt?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm. Dann setz die Kamera ab.
Hol einen Spieß.
[Musik]